so I'm just going to jump right into it
and I'll start with you Tony so Abe goes
on a wild Journey this season especially
when it comes to his grandkids I won't
go into too many specifics but I thought
that was one of my favorite storylines
of the show uh did you have a specific
Arc or storyline that you really enjoyed
filming over the last few seasons for
Abe I've enjoyed the whole Arc of uh
Abe's Arc from beginning to end because
every season sees him going through some
kind of large transition
um and and
for me you know just as an actor just
seeing where he started in the pilot and
where he ends up at the end of five it's
a very it's a long circuitous crazy
Journey
um a journey of
Discovery self-discovery and and so
Revelations and and uh
ultimately having to
um you know making beats with embracing
these these these changes in his life I
love that I love that the challenge of
that as an actor and then Marin I mean
getting a glimpse into Rose's life
especially not just
um what we see we see in the in the
current timeline but you know looking at
her life in full yeah yes yeah was there
a specific
um what was your reaction to reading
those scenes and getting to film those
moments without getting into too many
details yeah right so I'll be careful to
not say too much but you won't we won't
air this prior to like the audience
leading into it right I I was really
really touched by uh
the notion of of caretaking that Midge
has for her mom I mean they had a
complicated to say the least
relationship right and she was always
asking for her mother's approval and
just kind of respect and and then at the
end she's basically kind of distorting
the truth letting your mom believe that
she's got a very successful business and
that's that's kind of amazing and and
just was dropped in like there's like
one line about it right the way Amy and
Dan do that where you kind of have to
stop rewind and be like what just
happened what did she just say she's
gonna die she's not well she's going
away and yet the business we thought was
so successful and it wasn't so I was
really taken by that and of course Amy
and Dan were running through into the
next episodes and I wanted to stop them
in fact we're going to be all together
in the next week and I'm going to say
hey talk to me more about Rose's life
yeah tell me what all what else happened
but I was I was really I'm I'm deeply
intrigued by this woman I got to play
and she still feels like this other
person that I want to know more of so
it's that's that's one of the reasons
it's hard to say goodbye is I just
there's so much that still surprises me
about her yeah I mean I feel like
there's so many layers to Rose that we
we keep
revealed about
so much to dig into so I I really I
agree with you on that point
um you guys have had a great run this
with this series I think it's just uh
it's one of the best shows on television
right now in my opinion I think the
writing is fantastic the acting is
fantastic with it being over is there a
specific aspect of this show that you
guys are gonna miss and uh Tony I'll
start with you on that one oh I'm gonna
miss it all
um the writing was just Sublime you know
week in and week out uh working with
this Ensemble working with this crew
um working for me I think
more than anything is is being in a
story in this time period
um
I I just I love this time period to work
in without
cell phones and computers and
um
it it's it it I it's it interests me it
it it's it's fun to look at it it's
I I love the I love the sort of the the
the design elements of the clothes the
the props the furniture all of that
being in transported into that universe
that's uh that's that's the part I think
I'm gonna miss the most yeah you know
um
any show I work on or any play I get to
do any kind of anything to do with being
an artist and actors is has its own
unique great aspects I think that what
like thinking about your great question
is
this one
um
there's a little bit of awe in the room
at all moments true
yeah he says oh we would have read
throughs in which she would be like
still afterwards and you'd be or maybe
everybody would be uproariously like
applauding but it it nothing was done
like in a like small and Casual flip
flippant way the attention must be paid
like they treated Caroline was telling
me that Dan had said um Paladino had
said something about it being like
comedy is thought sometimes to be I'm
not beautiful or something and instead
they wanted to make sure like in other
words when you shoot it like just have
the faces and let's show everybody it's
funny funny but like they wanted it to
be filmic like a Scorsese film and
that's how we were treating it on set
like we're gonna get yeah there wasn't
there wasn't a moment of of you know
cynicism or of anyone like it's just a
job it was never just not for anyone
when you run for some jobs yes basically
it just is yeah yeah it's it's like get
through it it's a job it's a you know
yeah to our work will yeah you know
we'll we'll we're in 100 but it's a job
this was never like that yeah this was
special every day every day yeah and you
get the scripts and there wouldn't be
that much that would change no it was
like so right well crafted so well
crafted and in the read-through it was
that good remember we were told that
sometimes people who come to the read
throughs would be like that was a
performance that just happened I'm going
to like see a Broadway show or what have
you
um and so
that's I'll miss that I'll miss that
it's really it was like and I don't mean
Larger than Life like you know like you
know in a big old Broadway it just was
better than life usually sometimes guys
yeah yeah for sure I mean it definitely
feels that way when I'm watching it
there's definitely this sort of filmic
quality that I don't feel like I get a
lot with television that's right um so
it's so interesting to hear you guys say
that and sort of confirm my my thoughts
but um yeah I just want to thank you
guys so much to for speaking with me on
this because I I really enjoyed this
final season and I can't wait for
everybody to watch it it's just uh it's
a it's a great it's a great way to end
the show